anlässlich des bevorstehenden
österreichischen eu ratsvorsitzes
präsentierte verteidigungsminister mario
kunasek die sicherheitspolitischen
schwergewichte und beiträge des
bundesheeres
ich habe mir zwei schwergewicht
setzungen das eine sind
unterstützungsleistungen die wir treffen
im rahmen des flottenmanagements
mitfahrern chauffeuren aber auch
assistenzleistungen die entsprechend
auch vor fallen können nämlich für das
innenministerium wo wir auch kräfte
bereit halten und natürlich auch im
bereich der luftraum operation wo wir
auch zur luft auch für sicherheit sorgen
und der zweite große bereich ist der
inhaltliche bereich wo wir auch im
sicherheitspolitischen bereichen
natürlich auch uns einbringen werden
nämlich wenn es darum geht lösungen zu
finden
für die sicherung der eu-außengrenze als
beispiel wo wir mit dem assistenzeinsatz
modell das bereits seit jahrzehnten auch
in österreich auf hervorragende art und
weise gemeinsam mit der innen mit dem
innenressort gibt hier lösungen zu
finden
aber selbstverständlich auch an lösungen
für den westbalkan auch zu erarbeiten wo
ich ganz offen sage das ist ein bereich
wo man stabilität und frieden braucht
nur dann keine stabilität und frieden
auch in österreich und in europa gehen
neben der luftraumüberwachung gab auch
das kommando schnelle einsätze die erst
reaktions kraft des bundesheeres vor
journalisten in der maria theresien
kaserne einen kleinen einblick in ihre
fähigkeiten
das kommando schnelle einsätze ist ein
verband den es seit eineinhalb jahren
gibt es ist ein verband eine brigade der
so natürlich militärische aufgaben zu
erfüllen hat nichtsdestotrotz ist ein
verband der auch in den auftrag hat
nämlich unterstützung bei
aufrechterhaltung von sicherheit und
ordnung sollte das benötigt werden
sollte sie anforderungen sehr dass
sicherheitsbehörden geben wir haben also
verschiedenste fähigkeiten in diesem
verband
das beginnt von der militärstreife
elemente der arbeitsgruppe funktioniere
infanterie aufklärung logistik elemente
alle können in irgendeiner art und weise
dazu beitragen dass die
eu-ratspräsidentschaft sichergestellt
werden kann
das kommando logistik koordiniert das
umfangreiche eu transportmanagement für
den einsatz im rahmen der eu
ratspräsidentschaft erster juli bis 31
dezember werden die für von porsche
österreich an die 160 fahrzeuge
gesponsert die übergabe erfolgte
symbolisch durch den verteidigungs
nächste österreich hat nach 1998 und
2006 das dritte mal den vorsitz über die
eu-ratspräsidentschaft
das bundesheer ist großartig vorbereitet
das ist für uns nicht das erste mal dass
wir eine veranstaltung mit dieser auch
entsprechend abarbeiten das heißt ich
gehe davon aus dass hier es reibungslos
funktioniert appelliere aber natürlich
auch an alle die hier eingesetzt sind
diese verantwortung auch zu leben das
bundesheer auch darzustellen und werbung
im besten sinne zu machen wir leisten
viel und wir müssen es auch entsprechend
darstellen
deshalb freue ich mich auch auf die
nächsten sechs monate